en Argentine l'animosité contrôlait
français continue après la finale du
Mondial une pétition en ligne a été
lancée pour je cite que les français
arrêtent de pleurer elle a déjà récolté
plus de 700 000 signatures celui qui a
lancé la pétition indique que les
Français ne font que ce plaindre et
n'acceptent pas que l'Argentine soit
championne du monde une initiative qui
répond à une première pétition ayant
pour objectif de rejouer la finale de la
Coupe du Monde des supporters des Bleus
se sont pleins de l'arbitrage et du
comportement de certains joueurs de
l'albicellesse le Champion du Monde 2018
Adil Rami a vivement critiqué le gardien
argentin Emiliano Martinez défendu par
son coéquipier par haidès alors alors là
je d'accord mais d'accord c'est la bonne
réponse enfin je suis dubitatif Léa
Salame a déclaré ça fait 10 ans qu'on me
dit que je ressemble à Amy Winehouse
je ne sais pas je crois que c'est une
question de profil et si vous me
choucroutez les cheveux j'y crois pas
c'est surtout une question d'ophtalmo je
pense une marche d'hommage aux victimes
de l'attaque de vendredi rue d'Enghien à
Paris elle a lieu en ce moment même sur
les lieux de la fusillade placés sous
haute surveillance elle se déroule pour
leur pacifiquement les portraits des
trois cures d'assassinés ainsi que des
trois blessés sont en tête de cortège
c'est toute la communauté kurde qui se
sent menacée vous pensez que ça haine
était nourrie par un discours politique
par un discours politique et aussi par
des chaînes d'information on a une
chaîne cnews même pour pas la cité elle
passe son temps à faire des de
l'immigration son fonds de commerce sont
un fond de haine envers les étrangers
moi me demande c'est pas possible c'est
personne là il cherche il cherche à
créer une guerre civile Mélenchon
manifeste dès le premier jour son
intention d'exploiter autant qu'il le
peut les choses pour que ce fait divers
ne soit pas un simple fait divers et il
fait partie des gens qui sont nombreux
etc je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire qu'il est
complotiste encore que mais il fait
partie des gens raciste est un fait
divers et les gens qui regardent la télé
sont persuadés que c'est de pire en pire
que le vivre ensemble ne fonctionne plus
et c'était aussi une réalité et les
communautaires qui nous permettent
peut-être les communautaires pendant
Isaac Isaac
les communautaires subissent le racisme
donc ils se replient sur eux-mêmes et
les Identitaires
tout le temps pointé du doigt les
communautarisme et bah si si moi je
parle de faits divers parce que
je ne suis pas de ceux qui lorsqu'une
chose est simple disquelle est tellement
simple qu'elle peut pas être vrai ce
type est un dingue c'est tout je dis
n'importe quoi enfin tout ce qui me sort
par l'esprit mais en sachant que tout ce
que je dis c'est faux j'y pense pas une
seule mienne j'ai qu'une envie c'est de
mettre dans ma poche comme ça pour les
prochaines et les nations je peux en
retourner le cerveau d'une au moins la
justice de son côté n'a pas retenu à ce
stade le mobile terroriste défini par la
loi le fait de troubler gravement
l'ordre public par l'intimidation ou la
terreur de mon point de vue il n'y a pas
à chercher je dirais de schéma
terroriste classique on est tout
simplement face à quelqu'un qui
peut-être probablement passé sa journée
devant la télé et se nourrissait surtout
alimenter cette haine qui d'ailleurs a
trouvé un appui pour lui lors de ce
cambriolage ou cette tentative de
tentative de cambriolage qu'il a rendu à
moitié fou
[Musique]
en même temps
[Rires]
si on va plus vite peut-être qu'on va
faire de l'électricité les amis c'est un
acte terroriste cet homme
il est venu avec quatre chargeurs dans
le but d'éliminer le maximum de
personnes mais aujourd'hui on se sent
abandonné on se sent abandonné on se
sent trahi ils sont deux parce quand
Jordan barley là il parle de grand
remplacement le grand remplacement c'est
la théorie raciste qui a fait que le
gars du tir Christian il est parti
s'attaquer à des musulmans dans le
terrorisme
en l'occurrence en Nouvelle-Zélande mais
c'est ce gars là c'est pareil il voulait
s'en prendre à des immigrés hein voici
l'objet de toutes les polémiques ces
derniers jours regardez cette affiche du
département de la Vendée qui souhaite de
joyeuses fêtes une image religieuse et
bien cette image elle irrite notamment
les jeunes socialistes de Vendée et qui
voilà une atteinte à la laïcité du 20
centimes noires avec CRS la déesse des
moissons pour le tout premier Napoléon
III pendant l'Empire Pétain entre 40 et
44 jusqu'à Marianne multi dessiné par
les grands artistes comme Jean Cocteau
dans les années 60 Philippe de Villiers
qui a réagi c'est moi qui ai décidé en
1989 d'apposer sur les abribus le Noël
vendéen la Vendée est une vieille terre
chrétienne qui a payé pour cela vu au
nouveau Robespierre joyeux Noël tant que
nous sommes France 10 Philippe de
williami aimer les pieds dans le plat
quand on doit être léché par temps de
monde et il ne faut pas être trop trop
singulier il faut il faut que les gens
nous lèchent pas avec des goûts